vor gericht sind alle gleich so sieht es
der rechtsstaat für alle müssen sich an
dieselben gesetze halten und auf der
basis wird recht gesprochen
und doch gibt es immer wieder urteile
die man irgendwie nicht als gerecht
empfindet jörg kachelmann saß unschuldig
im gefängnis renate künast darf man
beleidigen zwei bekannte fälle in denen
recht und gerechtigkeit nach dem gefühl
vieler nicht zusammenpassten verteidiger
staatsanwalt richter
alle haben ihren eigenen blick auf eine
falle müssen gegenseite und immer öfter
auch die öffentlichkeit überzeugen
im namen des volkes wie gerecht ist das
recht darüber sprechen wir in dieser
filme zusammen
[Musik]
phoenix runde schönen guten abend ganz
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich freue
mich auf die diskussion mit diesen
gästen die im gerichtssaal ja alle eine
spezielle rolle hätten hier ist die
anwältin anja sturm gehörte mit wolfgang
heer und wolfgang stahl zum
verteidigungsteam von beate treppe die
hauptbeschuldigte im nsu prozess
herzlich willkommen der richter andreas
müller seit 1997 ist der jugendrichter
in bernau bei berlin wurde bekannt durch
unkonventionelle maßnahmen und außerdem
kämpft er auch für die legalisierung von
cannabis und die klägerin renate künast
von bündnis 90 die grünen sie haben sich
gegen beleidigungen im netz zur wehr
gesetzt und vor ihre karriere als
politikerin arbeiten arbeitete sie in
der jva berlin als sozialarbeiterin und
auch als rechtsanwältin eben auch eine
juristin hier am tisch und die
beobachterinnen gisela friedrichsen ist
deutschlands bekannteste
gerichtsreporterin jahrzehnte lang
begleitete sie prozesse für den spiegel
und jetzt für die welt frau künast
beginnen wir mit ihnen und ihrem fall
der hat viele menschen aufgeregt sie
haben sich zur wehr gesetzt gegen ja
übelste hass kommentare die wir hier
auch gar nicht gerne wiederholen mögen
und dann wurde gesagt und sie wollten
dass facebook die personenbezogene daten
von den verfassern eben raus gibt damit
man weiß wer das eigentlich geschrieben
hat da haben sie erstmal kein recht
bekommen was hat das mit ihrem
rechtsempfinden gemacht glücklicherweise
war ich schon geschult und gestellt das
ist ja ein unterschied zwischen meinem
subjektiven gerechtigkeitsempfinden gibt
und der frage was rechtsstaatliche
verfahren und prozesse bedeuten und
hatte mich vorher schon jede menge
geärgert über staatsanwaltschaften die
nämlich für solche und ähnliche posts
regelmäßig gesagt haben entweder
facebook die daten nicht raus oder das
ist noch keine beleidigungen
politikerinnen müssten das aushalten
ich war eigentlich eher geschockt über
die wucht das bei 22 post oder tweets
gesagt wurde
keine beleidigungen muss man aushalten
es wurde nicht richtig abgewogen und da
hat es mich dann auch wirklich gepackt
und ich gesagt also darauf konzentriere
ich mich jetzt ich habe eins gesehen
dass das recht in manchen situation und
was digitalisierung hate speech und so
anbetrifft auf alle fälle irgendwie
immer in der nacheile ist ja da
entwickeln sich neue methoden und dinge
und dann hat sich das gericht aber haben
sich staatsanwaltschaft damit noch gar
nicht auseinandergesetzt nicht
spezialisiert sie wissen gar nicht wie
das funktioniert dass solche
schimpfworte auch sexualisierte gewalt
androhen ewig im netz stehen wenn man
sie hier gelder stadt tauchen sie
woanders wieder auf also ich hab am
meisten glaube ich entgeistert in die
kälte die da drin war was man angeblich
aushalten muss und dass unvorbereitet
sein für die digitalisierung werde das
recht dass da hinterher hinkt sozusagen
müller wenn sie als richter recht
sprechen müssen haben sie das gefühl
dass sie da oder was ist so zu sagen
woran niveau nachrichten sie sich was
ist das wichtigste für sie wo damit sie
das gefühl haben ja das ist ein
richtiges urteil zum aller ersten mal
habe ich mich an das recht an das
geschriebene recht zu halten
das ist das recht wissen gesetzgeber
macht ein gesetzgeber macht aber
manchmal auch falsches recht gleichwohl
habe ich dieses recht anzuwenden
wir nehmen die ganze geschichte das
rechts nur der letzten 30 jahre
vergewaltigung in der ehe war nicht
strafbar züchtigungsrecht kinder war
nicht strafbar
homosexualität wurde bestraft aber
gleichwohl haben sich die richter in
dieses recht fast überwiegend gehalten
manchmal eben nicht und jetzt kommt es
dann dazu dass dieses recht im
gerichtssaal angewandt werden muss mit
allen tücken und den schwierigkeiten mit
formulierungen die der gesetzgeber
vorgegeben hat und dann haben sie die
angeklagte oder angeklagten dann haben
sie die verteidigerin haben sind
staatsanwalt und alle gucken ein
bisschen anders drauf und wenn sie auf
irgendeiner art gerechtigkeit
herbeiführen können dann wollen sie es
machen und das sehen sie daran wenn alle
zufrieden saal gehen dann haben sie es
irgendwie geschafft aber das ist leider
gottes nicht immer der fall und manchmal
ist es so dass gerade im zivilrecht ganz
logisch
eine solche verliert ja die sagt das ist
unrecht die andere seite sagt ist es
recht im strafverfahren ist es so der
wirt jemand freigesprochen da sagt die
geschädigte die mutmaßliche geschädigte
das ist unrecht andererseits hat der
richter dem alten guten spruch zu folgen
im zweifel für den angeklagten spreche
man einer frau friedrichsen
sie haben hat gesagt auch wenn alle
etwas unzufrieden auch gleich
unzufrieden sind dann ist es auch ein
gutes urteil ist richtig verstanden ja
durchaus
es gibt ja auch fälle muss ein
kompromiss gefunden werden der letztlich
niemand so ganz gut gefällt aber mit dem
alle leben können und dass das
herbeizuführen das ist eine große große
kunst zu frau künast also ich muss sagen
als ich das damals gelesen habe ich habe
das auch nicht verstanden
ich habe beim besten willen nicht
verstanden dass man gut sie ist eine
politikerin die öffentlichkeit steht da
gelten ein bisschen andere maßstäbe aber
solche beschimpfungen
die muss man sich doch auch als
politikerin nicht bieten lassen und er
das sind so dinge
ich meine das erfährt man als journalist
in genau so dass man etwas schreibt und
damit ist jemand nicht nicht
einverstanden und dann heißt ja das ist
noch noch meinungsäußerung und das ist
aber schon nicht mehr meinungsäußerung
ich möchte das verstehen können und das
kann ich manchmal nicht verstehen und da
gehört zum beispiel stockingers mit dazu
vorstellen wie haben sie denn wir haben
sie das wahrgenommen das urteil dass man
eben beleidigungen dieser art machen
kann sie sind ja auch eine person die
durch den nsu prozesse stark in der
öffentlichkeit standen also wie ist es
ihnen gegangen sie haben sicherlich auch
einige heftige kommentare ja also aber
es gab auch wir hatten eher bedrohungen
jetzt eigentlich weniger beleidigungen
wobei jetzt nicht so viele bedrohungen
was jetzt mich auch nicht so
beeinträchtigt hat was möglicherweise
auch er einfach daran lag dass ich mir
das nicht vorstellen kann aber ich habe
sehr wohl den fall von frau künast
mitverfolgt und muss ebenfalls zugeben
dass ich damals
extrem überrascht war in der tat mit
welcher kälte das gehandhabt wurde also
und das gefühl was da war war dass es
auf einmal einfach ein anderer maßstab
herangezogen wurde und und zwar nicht
nur der eine politikerin oder eine
person im öffentlichen leben zu sein und
ich glaube dann sind wir nämlich genau
bei dem thema gerechtigkeit und maßstab
und zwar sei maßstab wenn man eben das
gefühl hat auf einmal
hier werden unterschiedliche maßstäbe
angelegt da mal jemand politikerin ist
genau denn letztlich also eigentlich
meinungsäußerung oder eine
herabwürdigung bisschen also zu übelsten
beleidigungen das und da geht es auch
darum und das ist glaube ich der zweite
punkt und den ich auch gleich aufgreifen
würde dahinter 8 die staatsanwaltschaft
und auch die gerichte in so weit
hinterher dass dem das gefühl jetzt auch
was das ausmaß macht dass es nicht nur
in anführungszeichen um eine schwere
beleidigung geht die im eins zu eins
gespräch ausgesprochen wird auch nicht
schön ist aber in dem fall eine eine
eine ganz andere wucht hat und das
glaube ich insgesamt die es die digitale
welt ist noch nicht so richtig bei der
strafjustiz angekommen okay aber das ist
ja dann schwierig und wie wichtig ist es
dann frau künast das also sie fühlten
sich ungerecht behandelt durch das
gericht aber wie wichtig ist es dann
dass es dann so viel empörung gab dass
sie das gefühl hatten ja ich bin nicht
alleine mit meinem rechtsempfinden das
was die öffentlichkeit die
öffentlichkeit trägt das auf einmal
mithilft das dann ja das ist ein sehr
gutes gefühl und ich sage mal noch
besser war dass das und wieder ein
großteil der juristische welt sich
kritisch mit diesem beschluss des
landgerichts berlins auseinandergesetzt
hat es gegen 22 äußerungen und ich fand
es eigentlich sehr schön wo ich dann
überall in der fachliteratur ob digital
oder analog gelesen habe
der klare analysen dieser entscheidung
ja und da wurde so richtig ja manchmal
in aller schärfe gesagt also wie man
richtig subsumiert und was was das prüf
schema ist eigentlich relativ früh im
studium und warum haben es drei
richterinnen nicht hingekriegt
das kammergericht hat man viele wochen
später ja ich glaube bei 12 sachen
abhilfe geschaffen auf meine beschwerde
hin und für die anderen bin ich zum
bundesverfassungsgericht hat eine
beschwerde eingelegt die zu meiner
freude noch nicht entschieden ist sage
ich einfach mal so weil ich glaube wenn
sie meinen sie sind nicht annehmen
würden wer sich schon entschieden
und ich will aber in dem kontext diese
frage vielleicht normal antippen mit dem
begreifen was da passiert wenn wir über
rechtsstaat und recht und gerechtigkeit
reden dann haben wir reden wer immer
über erwartungen ja und und wer nutzt
was und ich glaube dass der dieser
digitale bereich ganz besonders auf
zeigt dass wir eigentlich eine mehr
atmende mitwachsende justiz brauchen ja
weil weil frau sturm hat gerade gesagt
also wenn jemand einem eimer das a wort
sagt da irgendwo dann ist es ja
irgendwie weg vielleicht erinnert man
sich später dran aber hier kommt es
immer wieder auf dem famila genau
kartiert eingesetzt und gezielt
eingesetzt und damit gibt es ganz andere
fahren und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
das wir nicht nur so im engeren sinne
rechtsstaatliche fragen hier verteidigen
sondern wir verteidigen an dieser stelle
unsere demokratie meine these ist die
zukunft unserer demokratie und unseres
rechtsstaat wird's im netz entschieden
weil dort wird ein neuer takt vorgegeben
und stellt sich die frage unsere alte
werte regeln und um dieses wissen wie
mechanismen eigentlich funktionieren ob
die eigentlich noch gelten und das würde
dann auch eher analoge rein was wir bei
vielen taten sehen ob ich würde gerne
mal auf diesem punkt kommt also diese
frage nach den nach der öffentlichkeit
frau friedrichsen welche rolle spielt
jetzt wenn wir auch über das netz reden
halt eben wie beispiel gerichtsprozesse
beobachtet werden wie angeklagte wie
darüber geschrieben wird dass die haben
ja durch das durch die sozialen medien
eine viel größere öffentlichkeit und es
gibt ja gar nicht mehr die ruhe
die sie früher vielleicht hatten am
anfang ihrer karriere wo sie in ganz in
ruhe einen gerichtsreportagen schreiben
konnten heute ist das alles schon
hundertmal auf twitter dann zu lesen
also was macht das mit dem also mit dem
bild dann der angeklagten zum beispiel
das ist für das bild der angeklagten
meistens desaströs weil natürlich die es
geht dann hauptsächlich um den
angeklagten sachverhalt der manchmal
sehr unfällen ist aber alles was
dazugehört war was warum diese tat
geschehen ist wer diese angeklagt ist
das interessiert alles nicht mehr
sondern es geht nur noch darum wer
dieser mensch definiert sich nur noch
über das was der die staatsanwaltschaft
anklage
genauso ist es eigentlich was mir sehr
missfällt dass auch die rolle der
verteidigung in diesen zeiten eigentlich
ganz andere geworden ist ich kann mich
nicht erinnern dass zu beginn meiner
tätigkeit verteidiger so angegriffen
worden sind und so auf eine stufe mit
denn mit ihren mandanten gestellt worden
so nach dem motto das ist ja so was
ähnliches wie ein komplize oder er hört
beide eingesperrt am besten die diese
einzelnen rollen im stall im
strafverfahren dass man auch dass man
nicht nur die anklage braucht sondern
dass man auch ein gegengewicht nämlich
die verteidigung brauchen das kommt
kommt da völlig abhanden sondern da wird
das verselbständigt sich dann auch im
netz nicht da gibt es ja dann keiner
sagt irgendwas tausend stimmen ihm zu
und klatschen beifall und fragen wird
machte man direkt die
pflichtverteidigerin ja wieder einmal
dagegen
sie hatten ja das war ein schwieriges
mandat mit der treppe zu verteidigen
wie würden sie das sagen welche
möglichkeiten hatten sie überhaupt noch
oder oder wie sehr wurde die
öffentlichkeit des weyher nennt ein
prozess der enorme der öffentlichkeit
stand überhaupt noch ihren ihren eigenen
punkt zu machen wobei artete so in der
öffentlichkeit statt
gut wir haben den antrag auf einstellung
des verfahrens gestellt unter anderem
darauf gestützt dass eine enorme
vorverurteilung stattfand und zwar gar
nicht so sehr die ideale sondern eben
auch durch die strafverfolgungsbehörden
das will ich jetzt gar nicht weiter
vertiefen sondern in dem zusammenhang
ist aber ein wesentlicher punkt der
sowohl bei frau künast sich eine rolle
spielt und auch bei dem was ich jetzt
ein paar friedrichsen sagte das was eben
eigentlich was ist denn das
rechtsstaatliche verfahren das ziel
eines strafprozesses ist ja die wahrheit
ermittlung und letztlich muss man halt
sagen in anführungszeichen selbst bei
den kleinen delikten oder wenn wir jetzt
eben über diese beleidigungs
kriminalität sprechen hate speech im
internet dann muss man einfach sagen
gehört es zur wahrheitsermittlung eben
dazu auf zu klären was dass das eben
nicht in einer eins-zu-eins-situation
bedeutet in welchem ausmaß das ganze
stattfindet also letztlich und welche
bedeutung das beispielsweise wenn man
das so weiter laufen ist für die
demokratie hat meines erachtens muss man
gar nicht so sehr heran gehen und sagen
wir müssen hier strafprozessuale oder
auch strafrechtlich als gesetzgeber
tätig werden sondern meines erachtens
kommt man mit dem was wir haben wenn man
es denn vernünftig anwenden würde und
diesem auftrag entsprechend nach käme
käme man damit ganz gut zurecht und aber
die frage war ja noch mal wie es ist für
sie als verteidigerin werden sie
sozusagen in werden sie in die werden
sie sozusagen zusammengefasst dass man
sagt ja sie sind ja auch genau wie
frauke ja also das der öffentlichkeit
oder ist nicht passiert kann ich weiß
ich nicht das finde ich jetzt gar nicht
so wichtig viel schlimmer und viel
wichtiger ist tatsächlich wiederum die
behinderung also presseberichterstattung
ist wichtig vierte gewalt im staat
wir haben die regelung zeugen sind
nacheinander zu übernehmen
beispielsweise also sprich in
abwesenheit des anderen
damit die zeugen unbeeinflusst von
einander bekunden zu dem was sie erlebt
haben
wenn aber alle zeugenaussagen
jetzt nachzulesen sind oder sofort
veröffentlicht werden
dann haben sie auf einmal eine eine
wahrheitsermittlung die im prinzip nicht
mal im rahmen eines steiner
hauptverhandlungen im gerichtssaal
stattfindet sondern die einfach draußen
in der gesellschaft in einem re
medienwelt stattfindet die welt hat sich
verändert
man muss jetzt erstmal so sagen also von
magneten job jetzt sicher seit 30 jahren
ja und auch vor 30 jahren gab es
natürlich prozesse auch welche die ich
selber geführt habe wo ich anschließend
der zeitung was gelesen habe was im saal
gar nicht stattgefunden und das gab es
damals das gibt es heute noch viel viel
mehr und es gibt eine vorverurteilung
teilweise durch die presse durch die
medien die nicht hinzunehmen sind
andererseits ist es so dass man viel
mehr auf die justiz schaut was macht die
justiz was macht die in bestimmten
fällen wie geht sie mit sexuellen
missbrauch um es wird vielmehr
kritisiert und ich denke auch dass die
justiz als teil dieser gesellschaft auch
kritisiert werden darf in dem einzelfall
im fall von frau kühn ist sicherlich ich
habe es auch gemacht also jetzt haben
wir gesehen bei dem fall von frau künast
das haben sie alle gesagt da hängt die
gesetzgebung hinterher eigentlich der
den tatsachen die wir im moment so haben
und wenn ich auch nicht so nicht
unbedingt sagen es gibt nun mal in
deutschland um die 20.000 richter und
alle setzen sich zusammen machen
entscheidungen manchmal sind drei
richter für eine entscheidung zuständig
wir wissen und nicht mehr wie es die
entscheidung ausgegangen 2 2 1 oder 3 zu
0 oder 1 0 dafür gibt es ja diesen
rechtsstaat der gestaffelt ist wenn die
erste instanz irgendwie ich sag's mal
mit einfachen worten scheiße baut kann
man die zweite gehen und man schon sogar
in die dritte aber wir sind bei gericht
natürlich nicht perfekt und glauben sie
nicht dass ich in meinen 30 jahren alles
richtig gemacht habe gibt es einen fall
den sie uns erzählen wo sie nachher
rausgegangen und haben daher gedacht
haben wir natürlich gibt es fälle dafür
gibt es ein straff entschädigungsgesetz
also ich habe ich kann mich an einen
fall
da ist jemand sieben monate in
untersuchungshaft gewesen ja und in der
hauptverhandlung nach einer
hervorragende recherche einer
polizeibeamtin das wären vergewaltigungs
verfahren ist der mann freigesprochen
und zwar nicht im zweifel für den
angeklagten sondern wegen erwiesener
unschuld aber ich habe ihn vorerst mal
in haft genommen das ist zum beispiel
natürlich gibt es fälle im leben eines
richters wo man anschließend sagt hast
du an diesem tag die richtige
entscheidung getroffen oder hast du die
falschen getroffen
aber dafür gibt es eben auch kämpferin
ja die sagen das geht nehmen wir nicht
hin wegen in die nächste instanz
frau fried dessen blieb würden sie denn
sagen weil es gibt ja schon fälle wo man
dann sagt das finde ich nicht gerecht
also ein fall war zum beispiel auch die
kassiererin die wegen eines pfandbons
entlassen worden ist hat auch viele
aufgeregt also es gibt ja fälle wo man
denkt das ist einfach nicht gerecht wo
ist ein punkt wo sie sagen wie schafft
man es dass mehr gerechtigkeit
hergestellt wird oder ist es gar nicht
nötig also ich sehe meine aufgabe als
journalistin durchaus darin mir
gerichtsprozesse anzuschauen und dann
dem leser dem geneigten oder dem
zuschauer oder zuhörer zu erklären warum
ist es zu diesem urteil gekommen welche
argumente haben welche rolle gespielt
haben die mir eingeleuchtet fand ich die
plausibel oder hat mich das alles sehr
sehr gewundert und damit dahingehend
meine ich ist die rolle der medien
eine ungeheuer wichtige leider gottes
ist es halt so heute dass diese mühe die
das kostet und auch finanziell kostet
die verlage was die nimmt kaum noch
jemand auf sich es geht schnell schnell
von es muss sofort ein bericht her es
muss sofort irgendwas getwittert werden
und so weiter und da leidet natürlich
die ganze veranstaltung darunter und da
kann ich dann auch nicht mehr meinem
beitrag zur gerechtigkeit oder zu dem
gerechtigkeitsempfinden der
öffentlichkeit beitragen indem
ich sage ja dass man ja auf den ersten
blick vielleicht so aussehen aber wenn
man sich die sache genauer angeschaut
und das habe ich gemacht dann verstehe
ich warum das gericht so und nicht
anders geurteilt hat sie haben eben
angesprochen die vorverurteilung durch
die medien da ist sicher sehr vieles
dran aber ich darf mal so ganz am rande
auch daran erinnern wie sehr die
strafverfolgung verfolgungsbehörden zum
beispiel an so einer vorverurteilung
mit mit tun wenn sie zum beispiel in
einem stadium wo man noch gar nichts
weiß schon den namen und die
einzelheiten eines höchst vagen verdacht
es schon mal veröffentlichen und in den
medien sozusagen anbieten dass die
natürlich gibt auch machen davon dass er
halt legen sich dann noch eine
prominente person nicht am letzten ganz
ganz schwierig weil sich niemand dem
vorwurf zu ziehen will dass man einen
promi irgendwie besser behandelt hat er
normalbürger frau kühn als würden sie
dem zustimmen
ja ich habe aber jetzt gezögert es gibt
viele implikationen da ein ich habe mich
jetzt eines bewegt auch nach dem beitrag
von herrn müller dass wir ja dass wir
schon differenzieren müssen bei den
bereichen über welche rechtsgebiet wäre
jeweils reden weil natürlich das
vertragsrecht im zivilrecht sozusagen
von zwei vertragspartnern ausgeht außer
man wegen bei der unerlaubten handlung
oder so das strafrecht hat ja eine ganz
andere aufgabe das ist die ultima ratio
das ist sozusagen die letzte leitplanke
das warnschild hier sagt start up here
bestrafe ich und dass er das tun haben
soll soll möglichst noch eine
regulierende wirkung oder präventive ob
das so ist und wie weit es ist lass ich
mal dahin stehen aber das ist ultima
ratio und da wenn der staat diesen stab
strafanspruch dann aus und ist ja
natürlich besonderen regeln unterworfen
zum beispiel im zweifel für den
angeklagten ja und dass das ist
natürlich manchmal schwer auszuhalten
dass jemand sagt ich wollte
gerechtigkeit mit einer
entscheidung mit einem urteil und jetzt
sagt das gericht am ende im zweifel für
den angeklagten ja oder das gericht sagt
ich bin ja das ist die oder den fordert
sind ich persönlich bin eigentlich
hundertprozentig überzeugt dass sie es
getan haben und beim nächsten mal gibt's
ja die schärfsten strafen aber nach dem
prozessrecht darf ich das darf bestimmte
beweise nicht benutzen und kann sie dann
deshalb auch gar nicht verurteilen und
davon aus das sind ja das erstmal das
muss man aushalten
aber er auch ein arbeitsrichter genau
und vielleicht kann man darüber noch
reden aber ich würde sagen dass das aber
eine andere materie ist über die man
reden muss der rechtsstaat will das
aushalten weil er sich entschieden hat
lieber das auszuhalten als jemand
fälschlich zuvor us gibt auch den
anderen bereich der große
ungerechtigkeit gefühle auch bei mir
selber auslöst wenn ich mir angucke zum
beispiel im strafrecht was ist denn
strafe
ich will nur sagen hersteller ist auch
der gesetzgeber das ist für uns auch
mühevoll zum beispiel bei den illegalen
autorennen dass man da eine verabredung
nachweisen müssen und am ende stirbt
einer das hat mich lange angetrieben und
das ist viel arbeit den tatbestand zu
verändern einschließlich beschlagnahme
sofortigen wegfall führerschein und so
weiter
da gibt's oder oder die vergewaltigung
in der vielleicht die schwerpunkte
sorgen aber klagen ja das muss man
meines 802 komplex und vorteil nämlich
einmal die situation die sie auch mit
ansprachen dass wir beispielsweise genau
ein beweismittel haben und dass es nicht
verwertbar so und im prinzip liegt da
das beweismittel auf dem tisch was die
die täterschaft des angeklagten nach
weiß es ist nicht verwertbar der
angeklagte wird freigesprochen was aber
alle nicht immer lassen wir auch
geschafft worden ist die nicht egal war
oder irgendwas spielsweise genau so
wobei das jetzt ja nicht wirklich
das ist ja keine entscheidung im zweifel
für den angeklagten ist einfach ein
freispruch fertig aus
und das andere ist was ja vielfach so
ein bisschen durch die öffentlichkeit
medien geistert zu diese diese
freisprüche im zweifel angeklagten wir
alle haben sie diese endlich ja ganz
schöne vorstellung also bevor der
rechtsstaat da sein instrumentarium
rausholt und eine strafe ausspricht also
im zweifel spricht er mich frei wenn man
sich anschaut wie urteile begründet
werden müssen die verurteilen oder die
die frei sprechen dann erleben sie dass
das quasi die begründung steve umgekehrt
proportional ist sprich wenn sie
verurteilen müssen sie nur darlegen dass
sie überzeugt sind warum sie überzeugt
sind und im prinzip begründen war dass
sie überzeugend wie das überzeugt sein
dürfen ja es muss nicht mal im netz ist
muss nicht zwingend sein die
schlussfolgerung sie müssen nicht mehr
überwiegend wahrscheinlich sein
es muss einfach irgendwie begründet sein
wenn sie frei ein freisprechen das
urteil haben dann ist das gericht
gezwungen alle indizien im einzelnen
aufzulisten alle irgendwie in beziehung
zueinander zu setzen sich quasi alle
möglichen variationen die welche an
sachverhalten sich daraus bauen lassen
die alle noch strafrechtlich relevant
wären um dann am ende zu sagen das
reicht für uns insgesamt nicht
und dann haben sie nämlich ein recht
häufig beim bundesgerichtshof jedenfalls
entscheidungen wo dann doch ein
freispruch aufgehoben wird weil sie
sagen ja aber da hätten sie dann doch
noch mal das wäre genau nehmen das ist
nicht gleich so forderungen okay also
dieser dieser freispruch im zweifel für
den angeklagten das ist nichts worauf
man hoffnung oder vertrauen sie auch
beim 1
das war wir müssen ja auch sehen dass
nur die urteile durch die medien gehen
die auf irgendeine art zweifeln
unterschiedliche meinungen hervorrufen
die auf irgendeine art schlagzeilen
produzieren die 99 prozent aller urteile
die halbwegs okay
die gehen ja gar nicht durch die presse
es gehe nur teile durch die presse wo
bekannte dabei sind ja jetzt zum
beispiel kinderpornografie im fall
metzelder und so weiter ja das habe ich
das ist mein täglich brot bei mir wird
über diese verfahren nicht berichtet
möglicherweise wäre die presse dort
gewesen würde die zu dem gleichen
ergebnis kommen aber noch mal kohle
folgen haben denn diese öffentlichen
urteile dann also etwas auf die auf die
all die anderen
das hatten ist ein wahrnehmungsproblem
in der bevölkerung wenn sie immer nur
negative urteile und die gibt's
natürlich es gibt auch negative
handwerksleistungen und so weiter
ich weiß nicht ich kann dieses urteil
jetzt als juristen nicht unbedingt
kritisieren ja wir haben nunmal
strafraum die sind noch nicht hoch
gesetzt die werden in der von der im
moment hoch gesetzt das wird sehr
schwierig wir haben eine permanenten
wandel in der strafjustiz wir haben neue
ideen von politikern das müssen wir auch
alles erstmal umsetzen was da kommt da
sagt sie
hier wird die vermögensabschöpfung
eingeführt da wird ein neuer paragraph
eingeführt da wird dies eingeführt aber
auch richter müssen lanz immer sicher
mit klarkommen dann haben wir natürlich
und das muss ich noch immer glänzen zu
frau künast natürlich auch viel müll in
unserem strafgesetzbuch ja containern
erschleichen von dienstleistung diese
geschichte warum sind die im
strafgesetzbuch und natürlich werden
200.000 menschen jährlich wegen cannabis
verfolgt ich musste das hier an bringen
sie haben ja alles unsinnige
strafverfahren da sollte man doch den
gerichten viel mehr zeit geben und zeit
ist weiteres problem viel mehr zeit
geben um sich um den einzelfall sein
kümmern und nicht nur um den fall der
großen solange immer oder die verfahren
das durchschnitt wenn es um kleine
menschen gilt wird schnell wenn jetzt um
große sachen gilt dann geht sind
unheimlich verhandlungstage angesetzt
und so weiter insgesamt ist die
strafjustiz schwach und zeitnah nicht
orientiert ok
in einem punkt jahren müller
widersprechen gerne so schön
sie sagten eben die die medien kommen
immer dann wenn es irgendwie was zu
kritisieren gibt oder weil zu empörung
anlass ist oder die negativbeispiele
angeprangert werden können ich glaube
das stimmt nicht ganz
es gibt viele fälle die sind einfach
wegen der sache oder wegen des
juristischen problems das dahintersteckt
interessant und es gibt auch dinge bei
denen man durchaus mit einem urteil als
journalist einverstanden ist und es mit
mit mit überzeugung seinem dem
konsumenten erklärt warum das eine
richtige entscheidung gewesen ist und
nachvollziehbar ist also dass wir nur
auf das skandalhaus sind das mag
vielleicht für einzelne blätter geld sie
denkt sie haben das nie machen
zum beispiel hat es was die so genau
hier die sogenannte kinderpornografie so
war eigentlich sexuelle sexuelle gewalt
ja da hat es dann so viel rumoren
gegeben und so in bewegung und so dass
man dann noch mal richtig ran und
straftatbestände verändert verschärft
und so weiter und so dass man das
regelmäßig angucken muss weil es andere
bewegungsform gibt und so ist okay aber
am ende hängt an da drin hatten wir als
es aus dem bundestag aus cham richtung
bundesrat das kuriosum dass da drin war
dass es ein verbrechen ist so ein bild
zu besitzen ja also ich habe man hat
sich runtergeladen auf dem computer ein
verbrechen sozusagen ein bild zu
besitzen und es würde dann zb auch
heißen dass sie auch entsprechend zum
beispiel jungen leuten mit
entsprechenden maßnahmen oder an straf
rahmen begegnen müssen also 14 15
jährigen von denen ich sagen würde wir
sagen würden wenn man leute die sind so
viel im netz unterwegs die haben noch
nicht mal ein bewusstsein dafür wie
schwierig das ist und diese art der
einstufung ja da ist das ist einfach da
hat der gesetzgeber hyperventilierte
bestimmten straftaten wäre es besser
aber unsinnig sie wissen wie das
zustande gekommen ist das gesetz am
anfang hatte justizministerin gesagt so
weit will ich nicht dann weil der druck
von außen da ja und dann ist sie
hingegangen und hat dieses gesetz
gemacht warten sie mal 12 jahre ab was
aus diesem gesetz wird ja wir
höchstwahrscheinlich landet das auch
irgendwie ein ganz bald wieder in
da würde ich mir etwas mehr
widerstandskraft wünschen bisweilen wenn
bestimmte fälle in den medien hoch
gejubelt wie auch immer sich alle eben
überschlagen
und ich empfinde es inzwischen so ein
bisschen als ein undingen dass sich dann
sei es die justizministerin oder
generell politiker der verschiedenen
parteien erstmal hinstellen und zu einem
einzelnen fall konkret erklären lasse
das jetzt also dass sie das wirklich
entschieden ablehnen also so ein
bisschen diese tendenz dass im prinzip
jeder normale bürger der also jetzt
nicht permanent gefahr geneigt ist
straftaten zu begehen erstmal quasi
permanent erklären muss ich bin auch
gegen die begehung von straftaten und
damit geht es jetzt nicht um die
diskussion über das erschleichen von
leistungen sondern wir sprechen von
schwerwiegenden straftaten und erstmal
dieser reflex zu betonen dass auch er
oder sie das wirklich ablehnt führt
irgendwie das führt weg von der sache
von dem von dem sachlichen blick und da
würde ich mir etwas mehr
widerstandskraft wünschen zur war eine
versachlichung beigetragen
um ganz gut nur und dann auch nicht
immer als dass das einfachste ist auch
immer dann support ok strafmaß dann wird
halt auch das erhöht das ist kosten
einigermaßen kostenneutral hinzubekommen
und dann lange das ganze wieder bei der
justiz okay für uns ich merke wie
kompliziert es ist halt eben mit der
gerechtigkeit und gerade auch dieses
zusammenspiel mit gesetzgeber und dem
justizsystem das ist kompliziert ich
würde sagen ein bisschen runterbrechen
herr hämmerle wo oder ich fragte
friedrichsen frau friedrichsen
was ist ein guter richter woran erkennen
sie als reporterin würde sagen ja das
ist ein guter richter wenn ich den
eindruck habe dass er wirklich
unabhängig ist dass er nicht
irgendwelchen dem zeitgeist allzu sehr
nachgibt oder sich von so einem druck
groß beeindrucken lässt wenn er auch die
distanz zu sich selber hat und ich
kannte mal einen richter der sagte der
befangen ist er hier im saal bin sicher
ich weil ich kenne die ganzen akten aber
damit hat er hat er signalisiert dass er
weiß um seine befangenheit und damit
umgehen kann
das hat man vermisst man manchmal und
wenn ich dann höre aus einem viel
diskutierten prozess aus der jüngsten
vergangenheit dass ein vorsitzende dem
angeklagten ja nicht auf sein
verteidiger zu hören
weißt du ob der verteidiger seriöser
oder unser user typ ist egal aber so ein
rad öffentlich ausgesprochen
und dann noch von teilen der medien
heftig beklatscht und von der
öffentlichkeit auch endlich mal einer
der den zeit wo der hammer hängt
dann finde ich das äußerst bedenklich
und so was möchte ich von einem richter
nicht hören wollen sie uns dann auch
verraten wer warten
das war im little princess und merke ja
da bin ich also ich bin wirklich
erschrocken als ich das gehört habe
ich hab' ich mach man habe mache meinen
job über 30 jahre so etwas habe ich noch
nie in einem gerichtssaal gehört okay er
mir da wohl merken sie denn ich habe ja
am anfang schon nach den kriterien
gefragt wenn es heißt man ist befangen
weil man die akten kennt was leistet
einen dennoch oder wo merken sie da muss
ich aufpassen dass ich eben mich auf die
akten konzentriere und nicht auf das
bild was was ich dann noch irgendwo im
netz sehen oder auf
nationale stimmung also wie wie schafft
man es dann wirklich unabhängig zu
bleiben wenn die man zunächst einmal das
gerecht anwendet indem man die
beteiligten anhört indem man versucht
eine vernünftige entscheidung
herbeizuführen und in dem man von
vornherein da reingeht also ich morgens
mal ins gericht und weiß nicht was ich
am abend mitbringe und dann bin ich um
gefangen
ja wenn die wenn ich erst mal reingehen
weil die mich kennen ja die meisten
angeklagt
die ist da die ist die idee ist da
manchmal ist sogar so also meinetwegen
den nachbarschafts prozesse wie ja erst
mal grundsätzlich findet man alle
unsympathisch ja ja das ist total und
aber da dürfen sie nicht hingehen und
sagen und so das steht die ampel
die ist da natürlich aber dass das führt
nicht dazu dass jemand nicht eventuell
eine milde strafe bekommt oder sonst was
natürlich werden sie als richter auch
begleitet von ihren eigenen auffassung
von ihren umgebung und sie werden
geleitet auch sicherlich durch die
medien nicht das ist klar wenn sie
morgens auf irgend wie die zeitung aus
schlagen da wurde wieder über einen
großen kinderpornoring debattiert in
sehr gegen denke ich in drei jahren
krieg ich die drei jahre so lange
braucht auch die justiz bist du bei mir
sind die kommen hier auch weil wir ja
dauert ewig lange justiz ist am boden
aber befangenheit ja ich kann ihnen ihr
jüngstes beispiel ist läuft gerade
befangenheitsantrag gegen richter müller
weil ich mich in der talkshow setzte
gelegentlich und für die legalisierung
von cannabis streit aber das ist
irgendwie schon einmalig in der
bundesrepublik deutsche ich würde
ergänzen oder wenn ich das gefühl habe
zum einen also ich würde mir wünschen
dass ein richter oder einen
also ein gericht der körper die
richterin einfach sich darüber bewusst
sind dass sie also dass letztlich was
frau wissen gerade sagte dass sie unter
umständen eine entscheidung falsch
treffen können wenn sie und sie merken
dass ob sie dort einen vorsitzenden eine
vorsitzende haben die im prinzip das
auch in betracht zieht oder aber und
dann kommen wir zum thema verteidigung
einen vorsitzenden haben der im prinzip
jede regung der verteidigung als
narzisstische kränkung erlebt nach dem
motto ich muss es ja ich muss ja alle
interessen waren also insbesondere auch
die des angeklagten oder der angeklagten
der oder die braucht keine verteidigerin
weil ich kümmere mich ja auch darum und
wenn sich die verteidigung guckt dann
ist das ja quasi das signal da habe ich
wohl was falsch gemacht und das erleben
sie relativ häufig und das sind dann
häufig fälle wo es irgendwann
konfliktreich wird was im prinzip er auf
einer psychischen oder psychologischen
ebene abläuft als dass man wirklich
sagen muss das ist jetzt rational warum
soll ich nicht eine entscheidung
kritisieren oder ein bestimmtes vorgehen
und möglicherweise habe ich sachliche
gründe und der andere sagt stimmt haben
sie vielleicht recht oder nähe aber ich
habe andere sachliche gründe kann man
doch machen und selbst der vorwurf oder
ein ablehnungsgesuch wegen besorgnis der
befangenheit damit sagt man im prinzip
noch nicht mal du bist befangen sondern
aber jedenfalls so will ich äußerst ist
es zu besorgen wenn man mal ganz ehrlich
ist ist halt der der geschulte richter
die geschulte richterin einfach achtet
sehr auf die wortwahl und dann siehst du
dass sie eben ja das nicht so deutlich
wie gibt ja es gibt ja auch laienrichter
es gibt auch schöpfen in deutschland
auch gerade beim jugend ist das da haben
sie den eindruck dass geht da gerecht
dazu ich finde das gut dass das schaffen
sind die schöffen bezeichnet man ja als
den gesunden menschenverstand so und nur
was ich war also ich bin seit 25 jahren
schöffenrichter und die schaffen
sind immer sehr zurückhaltend ich
wünsche mir manchmal richtig gute und
die können sehr wohl urteile entscheiden
ja das kriegt man so gar nicht mit
andere juristen können das im rot als in
der absetzung lesen vielleicht wenn ihr
vorsetzen überstimmt wurde das schreibt
ja so oder macht er manchmal für die
nächste instanz aber die schöffen sind
außerordentlich wichtige personen im
strafprozess und in manchen anderen
rechtsgebieten auch vor friedel sind sie
haben gelegt haben sie auch die
erfahrung gemacht dass schaffen
entscheidend sind und es gibt natürlich
solche und solche fälle immer es gibt
lichter die sind sehr dankbar dafür wenn
sie eben mit leuten sich auch
austauschen können die keine juristen
sind sondern die dieses mal ganz anderen
perspektive vielleicht sehen und den
plötzlich der der blick dadurch öffnet
wird für eine nordsee in der geschichte
die sie selbst noch gar nicht bedacht
haben es gibt andere richter die sagen
auch gerade diese schaffen
jetzt werde ich liebe das 1 0 an und
erklären wie das alles funktioniert ich
brauch das alles ich habe selber genug
verstand im kopf und so also das ist es
unterschiedlich aber ich glaube
grundsätzlich ist diese beteiligung so
wie wir sie hier haben wir haben ja
keine jury gott sei dank nicht sondern
wir haben eben nur so einen beitrag des
volkes stimme er es ist okay und warum
sagen sie gott sei dank habe keine
schülerin sowie sowohl in amerika oder
auch in österreich zum beispiel gab es
ja auch lange zeit was das bedeutet für
den strafprozess nicht es fängt dann an
dass man erst dass das die einzelnen
verfahrensbeteiligten also die die
staatsanwaltschaft genauso wie die
verteidigung diese seien erst mal von
ihrer überzeugung zu gewinnen suchen
und da wären dann also ich habe das in
österreich erlebt da wird dann ein
theater aufgeführt ist es ist also
wirklich filmreif oftmals bringt
letztlich gar nichts ist dienst der
selbstdarstellung und es gehört halt so
dazu halt so ist und am ende ist es dann
genauso dann wird noch einmal diese
ganze sache so aufgebaut und
nein dass das ist es besser so wie es
eben schneller und härter und noch
besser ich würde ganz gerne am schluss
einfach nochmal unsere titel frage an
sie alle stellen wenn es heißt im namen
des volkes und wenn wir jetzt beleuchtet
wie er das volk benutzen dazu nehmen
würden als schaffen im namen des volkes
wie gerecht ist das recht frau künast
was würden sie denn da sagen da ist es
unser recht wirklich gerecht oder muss
man sagen ja richtig große gerechtigkeit
gibt es gar nicht doch nur ist
gerechtigkeit wenn ich mal an bärbel
bohley satz den sie angeblich gesagt
haben soll wir wollen gerechtigkeit und
haben den rechtsstaat bekommen daran
erinnere das macht ja was auf das was in
einem rechtsstaat am ende als
gerechtigkeit rauskommt ist nicht nur
mein individuelles gefühl ja oder mein
eindruck wie ich es leid wegen erlebt
habe als beteiligter irgendwo sondern
der rechtsstaat zeichnet sich dadurch
aus dass er um fehlurteile und
manipulation und so bei beweisen und so
zu vermeiden dass er wirklich klare auch
prozessregeln und so weiter hat und
anforderungen an die klarheit und
bestimmtheit von gesetzes regeln und und
und ich glaube also da werden die beiden
begriffe manchmal verwechselt oder
identisch genommen was sie nicht sind
aber am ende ist das ein richtig
lebenswertes land das sich möglichst
weit an diesem prozess regeln hält weil
nämlich viel verurteilung und fehler
vermeiden kann so ganz kurz ich weiß ob
sie bei das kurz beantworten können wie
gerecht ist das gericht immer abhängig
von den mitspielern des rechts und von
der gesetzgebung ist die gesetze muss
schlecht ist es nicht gerecht aber wir
werden keine perfektion erreichen okay
das ist so und was der was der
rechtsstaat macht ist letztendlich
rechtsfrieden schaffen
also ich würde sagen es rechtsstaat ist
unbequem es geht immer um grenzbereiche
und grauzone insofern wird es immer weil
es eben nur eine das
gesamtgesellschaftliche
gerechtigkeitsempfinden geht wird es
immer welche geben die sagen das passt
nicht aber im großen und ganzen muss ich
sagen leben wir hier in einem sehr
agenten start gewesen dass die kleinen
ganz klein sagt ganz kleinen tropfen
essig daran diesen also recht und
gerechtigkeit haben für meine begriffe
nicht sehr viel miteinander zu tun
das recht ist festgeschrieben ist ändert
sich zwar auch aber es ist steht man
kann es nachlesen und der gerechtigkeit
versteht jeder was anderes aus seiner
perspektive aus seinen motiven heraus
gerechtigkeit kann geübt oder muss geübt
werden oder strebt danach dass die in
diesem zustand zu erreichen okay und
dabei hilft das recht dabei hilft das
recht okay gut gut wir sind am ende
dieser wendung und könnten hier noch
stundenlang weiter reden mit viel
juristischem sachverstand ganz herzlich
dankt frau friedrichsen frau künast herr
müller und frau sturm und sie finden bei
phoenix in der mediathek und dann auch
in der ard mediathek jede menge zu
diesem thema recht und gerechtigkeit
also nicht nur unsere diskussionen
sondern auch noch spannende
dokumentation können sie alles noch
nachschauen und ich freue mich wenn sie
wieder bei der runde einschalten bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]